so the example of the bank we've been
studying we actually you know kind of
doing it in real time and i was doing
this on the fly we actually showed how
this bank got quote unquote bailed out
and it got bailed out by the sovereign
wealth fund because when this last piece
of debt came due it couldn't sell its
cdos for enough money to pay off that
debt so they just kind of held fast and
didn't sell their cdo's they couldn't
get any any other loans to pay off this
loan but what they were able to do is to
convince some foreigners who are
enamored by the brand of this you know
this institution of american capitalism
so they were willing to buy some shares
in this company and essentially bail it
out so in the example we used to have
500 million shares the company issued
another 2 billion shares sold them at a
dollar 50 per share and they got three
billion dollars for it and then so we
had three billion dollars in cash we had
a billion before so then we had four
billion we could pay off the loan with
uh with three billion of the cash and
then we're left with one billion dollars
left
and now this company would have let's
see if you have a billion cash and four
billion of cdos it would think that it
has five billion dollars of assets
if these are really worth four billion
dollars it has no liabilities so it has
five billion dollars of equity notice
the equity doesn't change when you take
some of your assets and you get what
you're
if when you if you get the value of the
assets that you think they're worth and
you pay off some liabilities it doesn't
change the value of your equity but
what's happened now well one this is
just you know just to get comfortable
with some of the terminology terminology
this company now is completely
de-levered because it has no it has no
liabilities it has no debt and its
assets are equal to its equity and
you'll find that a lot of companies that
are you know startups and
technology companies a lot of those have
very little debt and so they're
completely delivered anyway that was
just a side but this was an example of
how a company could get bailed out and
who lost here well the shareholders lost
right because
before you there was only 500 million
shares that split up the equity and now
there's 2.5 billion shares to split this
equity so the book value of the shares
if you even believe that these are
really worth four billion they went from
four dollars to two dollars i think this
is an important aside here because i
know i've mentioned before that you know
this the market price when you buy or
sell a share
it's just transacting between another
person who used to be holding that share
right so how does it affect the company
well it affects the company when the
company needs to raise more money and
that's what happened in this example the
company had to raise more money had to
go to this maybe it was you know the
government of singapore's sovereign
wealth fund and they say government of
singapore please invest in us buy some
of our shares and when when the
government of singapore when any
investor wants to buy new shares they
use the market value what that stock is
trading at as a good reference point for
what you might have to pay for those
shares oftentimes if it's kind of a
desperate situation and this person is
kind of saving you they'll pay below the
market price
but sometimes if they say oh this is a
lucky opportunity to get such a large
number of shares and essentially take
control of the company i might pay a
little premium over it so i'll pay two
dollars per share which was a little bit
of premium over the the market value at
the time which was a dollar but anyway
that's why the the market price of
something in the secondary markets where
a share is just trading between people
who aren't related to the company why
that's important because when the
company needs to raise money that is
used as kind of the fair market value of
a company shares but anyway this was a
the situation where the company gets
bailed out but what happens in the
situation where it doesn't get bailed
out
let's do that let's say that the
sovereign wealth fund never happened
let me clear this
let me see if i can
so
the
assets
i'll just write assets had a
billion dollars of cash
1 billion cash
and we have these 4 billion of cdos
cdos
for a total of five billion dollars
the liabilities
see we had a we had loan c
is coming due
for three billion dollars
and then you had the equity
which is essentially the total assets
minus the liability so that's two
billion dollars
and that split amongst 500 million
shares 500 million shares
right and that tells you that the book
value per share is four dollars
four dollars of book value per share
we're not going to worry right now what
the market value of the shares are
so let's say they shop everything around
all of these sovereign wealth funds
they've got burned because they invested
in citibank last year and the stock just
continued to plummet they invested in
all of the i think they invested you
know merrill lynch all of these they
invested in and they just continued to
plummet so they've been burned they
don't want to be the you know the last
guy holding the potato so there's no one
who's willing to invest equity so it
just forces the issue these people loan
c they say you know what
we're not going to give you a new loan
you can't pay this loan because even if
you sold the cdos you're only getting a
dollar for them so we are going to force
you into bankruptcy and that's how
bankruptcy happens when what when you
break one of the they call you know the
covenants with one of the people who
lent you money the covenant say you know
if you don't pay a loan within this
amount of time or somewhat some other
thing happens to your financials you are
then declared um insolvent and you go
into bankruptcy
and what happens in bankruptcy well in
bankruptcy you the the bankruptcy courts
take receivership of all of your assets
so the bankruptcy courts take
receivership of all of the assets so
they just say okay we're gonna this is
what you own
and you might get some we're not going
to go into the details now i'll maybe do
a whole series of videos on the the
details of bankruptcy you might get some
type of loan that helps you just
continue to do business because people
have to figure out if are they just
going to restructure your your
liabilities are they just going to
dissolve you because you're not you know
a viable you're not a viable entity
anymore
but anyway the bankruptcy will take hold
of you and essentially let's assume that
they're going to dissolve you um
they will then split you amongst the
stakeholders the people who you owe
money to and actually no let's say let's
not say that they dissolve you let's say
that everyone agrees that this brand is
worth a lot you know whatever we call it
um goldman lynch or you know lehman
sachs whatever our brand is it's worth a
lot no one wants to see it disappear so
what happens when you go into bankruptcy
well the creditors get first dibs on
everything so one way to think of it is
loan c
gets first dibs
on the assets and then anything that's
left over goes to the equity holders
so let's say the lone c guys they say
you know what we like this we want to
keep this bank as an ongoing entity but
what we want to do is
we don't let's just we just want to dump
these cdos
so the bankruptcy record okay yeah we'll
liquidate these cdos just because
everyone agrees that they're really
shady so they sell them and they only
get a billion dollars for them
so they get a billion dollars for the
cdo so now we have two billion dollars
of assets
it's essentially two billion of cash
right because we got
a billion of cash for those so two
billion of cash that's all that there is
plus there's you know i mean there's
probably some buildings and all that
which we're not listing here but there's
the brand and all of that
this guy's owed three billion dollars so
he says okay fine you know what i'm
gonna do i'm gonna keep this company
running
i'm owed two billion dollars i'm gonna
keep that two billion dollars in there
but what i get is essentially i get
all of the new shares of the company so
what essentially the bankruptcies court
is going to do they're going to create a
new corporate entity they're going to
put all of these assets into it and then
issue another i don't know 100 million
shares so they'll essentially create a
new entity where the new entity say has
2 billion of
assets
2 billion of cash
and let's say it has no debt or actually
maybe these people they say you know
what we'll even we'll even give you some
money because these are the people i
don't want to confuse things so let's
say that you have no debt so you have
2 billion of equity
and let's say that there are 100 million
shares 100 million not dollars 100
million shares
so the book value of the new shares is
20 per share
and you might say wow that's great
someone could have gotten these shares
for you know whatever they were i said
they were trading for before they could
have gotten them for a dollar per share
before now they're worth twenty dollars
per share but no that's not the case
it's actually horrible
these shares the shares of the old
company are worth zero because when you
liquidated the company or at least when
you tried to value the company or what
was we didn't liquidate it because we
were we're saying we still want to
create we still want the company to
continue its operations but we're saying
that the value of the company is only 2
billion this guy's owed 3 billion
dollars so he says you know what
i should get the whole company and i'm
still getting you know not everything
that i deserve but i'm going to get the
whole company so essentially whoever
lent loanc
all of these shares are now their shares
and the equity holders get wiped out the
old equity holders so those shares go to
zero
and so this is an interesting example
because i've seen people on cnbc say oh
what a great deal i could buy
shares of lehman brothers for you know i
don't know a dollar right but that's not
the case because you know they'll say oh
lehman brothers has all these assets and
it's never going to completely disappear
that might be true to some degree but
lehman brothers assets might be greater
than its liabilities which means that
its equity is actually worth negative so
that dollar isn't a great deal if you
really thought that lehman brothers in
the long term was going to come back
what you might want to do is somehow try
to become one of its bondholders and
then when it goes through bankruptcy on
the other side of the bankruptcy you
might end up in shares of the new
bank whatever it's called you know
goldman brothers or whatever anyway i
realize i'm out of time in the next
video i'm going to put it all together
and show you
one why our financial system is freezing
and two what the government's bailout is
attempting to do see in the next video